ce n'est pas une mais deux 4l qui roule
plein gaz sur cette piste au volant
quatre étudiants en bts à l'institution
notre dame à chartres ils viennent de
récupérer ces bolides
fraîchement sortie du contrôle technique
c'est une découverte
j'avais jamais conduite quatre années
auparavant vraiment c'est une première
fois après on s'y adapte vite et c'est
vrai que c'est la conduite est beaucoup
plus dur
mais d'un côté c'est beaucoup plus sympa
aussi je trouve il leur reste un mois et
demi pour s'entraîner à la conduite mais
aussi récolter des fournitures scolaires
et sportives qu'ils distribueront aux
enfants marocains défavorisés
on va essayer d'en ramener le plus pur
quand même pour les enfants ce que c'est
quand même pour l'association les
enfants du désert
donc l'objectif c'est quand même leur
faire plaisir et d'en ramener un maximum
le but du 4 l trophy est en effet
solidaire encore faut-il aller au bout
de l'aventuré
pour cela les pilotes profitent de ces
sessions d'entraînement pour se
familiariser avec la mécanique d'antan
en cas de panne
l'expert du groupe
c'est luca qui a étudié la maintenance
automobile même s'ils sont censés partir
en binôme chacun s'entraide pour relever
ce défi sportif c'est sûrement là de
faire c'est plus de 6000 kilomètres en
plus dans le désert d'avoir en fait
c'est une aventure humanitaire mais
mélangé à paarl autre chose le côté
voilà sportif qui m'a un petit peu donné
envie aussi et en voiture donc c'est
plutôt cool aux sessions les quatre
chars trains partiront le 17 février
pour biarritz d'où se lancera ce rallye
raid
direction les dunes du sahara